pascal muller bonsoir bonsoir alors
c'est la soeur de karen mulder vous êtes
deux soeurs c'est ça oui votre père
était inspecteur des impôts et votre
maman mais ma femme et mère de famille
votre enfant s'est déroulée comme en bas
par an très gentil qui nous aimait
beaucoup et voilà normal
alors comme karen mulder vous avez été
mannequin vous avez été actrice en vous
a vu en 1996 dans les deux papa et la
maman en 1998 dans bimboland est déjà
mort et en 2000 dans la plage avec
leonardo dicaprio
vous venez également de publier un roman
en hollande qui va bientôt sortir en
france oui octobre recevra
voilà alors l'histoire on la connaît
évidemment fin octobre 2001
karen mulder que je ne connaissais pas
du tout me contacter et elle me dit
qu'elle a des révélations à faire au
sujet de l' agence élite le 31 octobre
2001 elle est ici sur ce plateau et
rapidement je découvre qu'elle est pas
dans son état normal qu'elle est dans
une espèce de délire paranoïaque où elle
affirme avoir été plusieurs fois violé
sous hypnose
d'abord par son père à l'âge de deux ans
et ensuite par des stars du show
business très récemment je décide
évidemment d'arrêter l'interview élus
décidant avec catherine barma la
coproductrice de l'émission et michèle
cotta la directrice générale de france 2
bien entendu de ne pas diffuser cette
interview au moment où j'arrête
l'interview karen mulder s'en va en me
disant au moment où elle rentre dans sa
voiture que moi aussi je fais partie du
grand complot contre elle
évidemment nous ne souhaitions pas que
cette affaire s'ébruite mais il y avait
un certain nombre de gens dans le dans
le public qu'ils ont rapporté à des
médias sur internet en en rajoutant un
peu d'ailleurs certaines fois alors
évidemment
prévenu par jean yves le fur trois jours
après cet épisode tragique avec la corde
évidemment de vos parents vous décidez
de faire entrer karen dans une clinique
des alentours de paris voilà mais
malheureusement la rumeur s'est
amplifiée on à raconter des trucs
terribles certains journaux ont eu des
comportements à la limite du correct et
aujourd'hui vous êtes là un petit peu
pour faire taire la rumeur pour
expliquer ce qu'il en est vraiment parce
que moi je l' ai dit plusieurs fois mais
apparemment ça suffit pas il ya encore
une interview publiée récemment de karen
dans un dans un hebdomadaire donc voilà
je vous demande aujourd'hui d'abord
comment va-t-elle tout simplement pas
elle va beaucoup mieux déjà
elle est dans une clinique en dehors de
paris donc elle fait du sport elle se
balade se soigne et bon allez luan de
médias ce qui est voilà c'est exactement
comme
comme vous dites qu'il ya les médias qui
bon qui en rajoute énormément qui
fantasme sur cette histoire qui est qui
qui en font la sphère karen mulder et
quand il n'y a pas une affaire quoi par
exemple quand elle est rentrée en
clinique
elle allait elle a est très bien réalisé
deux semaines d'aller dîner avec elle
les a mis là passer le week-end chez
elles ou après leur entrée dans clinique
où ça allait très bien jusqu'au moment
où pas ce post a effectivement elle est
pas seul et peut-être quelqu'un qui les
a montré une journal où était mon
soi-disant disait c'est ce qu'est ce qui
aurait passé ici en rajouter des terres
ajoutons des tonnes et donc elle rechute
donc pour elle c'est très mauvais
donc voilà il faut faire attention parce
que c'est quelqu'un de malade et il faut
la traiter avec discernement vous pensez
qu'elle qu'elle pourra sortir dans
combien de temps 1 combien de temps je
sais pas c'est difficile à dire je pense
que c'est très bien que c'est soigné
qu'elle est probablement bien
voilà mais c'est difficile avec ce genre
de chose de dire mais bon j'espère que
dans un mois ou deux cas ici à ma place
les médecins sont confiants
alors évidemment tout ça vient sans
doute du fait que l arrêté d'être
mannequin un certain moment et à ce
moment là la colle une dépression c'est
ça non oui parce que déjà pour elle
parce que le truc avec karen sait que
c'est quelqu'un d'extrêmement gentil de
excessivement sensible c'est quelqu'un
de très pur c'est pas un requin ce qui
aurait peut-être été mieux ne sont qu'à
2 parce que le truc d'être mannequin
c'est quand même quelque chose ça c'est
dur donc quand il a raté deux bon il ya
quatre ans elle était elle avait
vraiment grosse fatigue donc elle a été
voir un psy qu analyste qui n'a pas été
très bien très mauvaise psychanalyse une
dépression et à la fin tout ça cesse a
cristallisé dont cérons est bouffée
délirante est bon pour moi même j'ai
appelé cette psychanalyste bon je sais
pas combien de fois jamais de réponse
est lettre recommandée jamais de réponse
et j'ai porté plainte elle a la bonne
femme
s'intéresse pas quoi peut-être que cette
psychanalyse a ouvert des portes en
ailes que la psychanalyste n'a pas sur
faire mais d'une certaine façon voilà et
là elle a trouvé des ports qui avait pas
à les inventer des portes tu ne sais pas
quoi mais c'est personnellement je pense
que ça a été très très mauvais voilà
ouais dans son enfance avait déjà eu des
choses comme ça où c'est vraiment la
première fois qu'elle est dans cet état
là ah ouais ouais
oui parce que vraiment on était quand on
était petit on était on a été très
copine tu sais la foule en france qu'on
a eu et a pas eu un truc bizarre l'a pas
eu
c'est à dire qu'il n'y avait pas des
trucs bizarres donc donc voilà donc
après ce qui est ce qui est ce que je
trouve très difficile avec la presse
notamment des trucs comme qu'on veut et
sd c'est qu'il ya des gens dont les dans
les journaux qui là ils sont en train de
gagner de l'argent sur l'az sur la
souffrance de quelqu'un oui et je trouve
que c'est dégueulasse mais c'est
absolument horrible avons ni seulement
vsd moi aussi les autres qui en vend ce
truc voilà on veut les faire passer pour
folle parce qu'il ya des choses à dire
que ils vont cacher n'importe quoi ces
gens là ils savent d'abord pas de quoi
il parle et c'est vraiment fait pour
gagner de l'argent et c'est la tristesse
mais on énorme mais c'est le manque de
humanité qui va très loin quoi écouter
c'est ce cas merci de votre témoignage
si vous aviez quelque chose à dire aux
gens de presse aujourd'hui vous diriez
quoi vous diriez quoi je le redirai
voilà je leur dirai que de laisser
d'abord là c'est ma seule tranquille'
colle à halle en train de l est en train
de guérir d'aller mieux de respecter sa
guérison est bon surtout d'arrêter de
parler cette affaire mulder parce qu'il
y en a pas
pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux